ja ich bin ja das ist ich kann das Wort
ja nicht mehr hören ich bin unschuldig
Punkt
im Zuge des Verfahrens und im Laufe der
Jahre hat sie aber immer mehr aus seiner
Sicht verdichtet dass hier der falsche
Vorteil ist ich weiß noch wie absolut
geschockt ich war diese Gegend war so
vollkommen die wirkte so vollkommen
sicher ich glaube das wäre mal zurück
unschuldig ist jeder der das Urteil
liest merkt schnell es gibt keine
Beweise nur Indizien und auch die
Indizien sind mehr als dünn
der idyllische Ammersee am 15 September
ein zehnjähriges Mädchen wird auf dem
Nachhauseweg vom Fahrrad gerissen in
eine Kiste gesperrt und vergraben
[Musik]
die Familie soll zwei Millionen D-Mark
Lösegeld zahlen doch dazu kommt es nicht
die kleine Ursula stirbt vorher
[Musik]
ganz Deutschland hält den Atem an so ein
grausames Verbrechen hat es hier noch
nie gegeben
27 Jahre bleibt der Fall ungelöst erst
2010 verurteilt das Landgericht Augsburg
Werner matzurek zu lebenslange Haft bis
heute ist unklar ob der Täter alleine
handelte oder einen Komplizen hatte das
Urteil ist wackelig stützt sich
hauptsächlich auf ein umstrittenes
Tonband Gutachten und ein widerrufenes
Geständnis aber neue Gutachten könnten
jetzt seine Unschuld beweisen und sogar
Ursel Hermanns Bruder Michael ist
überzeugt Werner Mazurek ist nicht der
Täter
eine Spur führt in einflussreiche Kreise
bis zum 28 Mai entscheidet das Gericht
ob Werner mal zurück vorzeitig aus dem
Gefängnis entlassen wird dann ist die
mindesthaftdauer von 15 Jahren um
draußen in Freiheit will der Verurteilte
Killer auf die Jagd nach dem für ihn
waren Killer gehen
[Musik]